all right everyone is excited to go in
the backyard because we've been seeing a
lot of movement back here so we think
there's gonna be a lot of updates so we
got mama
taika right there and the first thing
that you can notice is they're removing
these pavers and they're stacking them
nicely
because we're about to swap these bad
boys out with the big uh porcelain
pavers over here
these really nice ones
over here
and the reason why they're stacking them
nicely is in the front yard we're going
to expand the driveway so to kind of be
you know
cost efficient we're like why don't we
just use the pavers in the back for the
front because it's in Pavers you okay
dude you tripped on the Rope
hey mister are you okay
actually it's a rope okay mama can you
check up the ropes okay
yeah
yeah so they got these little ropes to
to show where the
the pavers and the
puppy and oh look at that Mama they got
the whole border down oh
look at that
you all right dude
no oh no what are we gonna do gotta take
to the hospital
they dead
our pool is taking shape
so over here we got the hot tub
where
yep we're gonna have a cool fireplace
dude we can roast marshmallows Isn't
that cool
yep make quackers
that's where the fireplace is gonna be
don't step on that
is still wet as you can see
it's very wet but they're putting these
little steps up
oh I like this little area right here so
glad our neighbors neighbors are doing
their yard too so they put up the they
made the fence a little bit higher which
is perfect because now that we stand
here
for sure oh that's true and they made it
higher so we get to reap the reward of
that
it's wet dude you can tell that's wet
why are you stepping on it go on over
there
I mean your uh cooking area is going to
be over there oh yeah some of the
Furnitures here now all right so this is
uh not a Furniture I messed up the
appliances
we got
a little fridge for our backyard kitchen
and we got the all-new Summer Set
Sizzler Pro baby
come out to here right yep do you even
know what the summer sets is are both
all about
no I don't know I don't know but yeah
it's gonna come out here so they got the
gas line they got the electricity plug
it all up I'll be here somewhere we can
start roasting and Grilling on the
backyard bro I'm rude but we can meal
prep make yummy food back here while
everyone's hanging out and chilling oh
just even feeling like all the wind and
that's hanging out back here yeah it
feels really good already
we can enjoy it right now because the
weather we get to enjoy it right when it
hits like September too
okay quick little update while I'm
working and I wanted to capture this
because I am going out of town and I'm
scared there's going to be so much
progress that I can't even catch up all
the little steps that they did so they
removed all the pavers now
as you can see and they laid a layer of
gravel and sand and they're making it
wet so that this guy can go around and
make everything super even
because after this step they're going to
put all those porcelain and start laying
it and it's the same porcelain that we
see on the far end of the pool you see
that light gray over there
and we chose that because we really
wanted to brighten up the backyard so
right now most of our house is brown
that was something we could not choose
because we got this house I wouldn't say
like in the beginning beginning because
if you choose it at the if you get the
house at the beginning beginning of a
new development you could choose like 99
of everything we got it after I would
say like phase one so we were able to
choose like 90 which is everything that
you see like on the inside but the
outside we couldn't choose so the
outside is that brown that wall is brown
the dirt's brown I guess the mountains
back there are brown so it was a very
brown house so we wanted to like
brighten it up kind of like what we did
with the inside like in here everything
looks very bright and it's still neutral
tones but it's just like um with like
pops of color but it's like a very
bright feel and we wanted to carry that
bright feeling to the outside so we
chose that porcelain that's going to
reflect the sun it's gonna look really
nice coming from this tile going out
there and the whole backyard is going to
be
really bright I see like more and more
workers coming in so that makes me
extremely happy oh
because for a while there's only one guy
working and I think he's probably doing
like the more delicate stuff but I think
they're building the outdoor kitchen now
which is tight look at that
here we go here we go
it's coming together
all right day three update three because
the workers just left which means it's
time for us to spy on our own house and
see what is cool going on so first of
all they got this super soft sand that
they put everywhere I think it's like a
leveling type of sand oh you see that
look at that oh
oh that's for the awning hey monkey do
you know what an awning is
it's gonna be this little roof that
comes on to keep us nice and cool in the
shade
for the outdoor kitchen and dining area
oh damn look at that
looking pretty good we're gonna be
grilling yep Grilling and Chilling yeah
the fridge goes right there
girl goes right there got that Somerset
Sizzler Pro I've been saying and then
they started expanding
on these tiles look at that
oh
hey monkey don't step on it okay
because I don't know what they want what
they're supposed to do so
it's probably something very specific
yep
Papa just told you I just told get off
oh my goodness see why you got to say
something the same thing a million times
don't touch anything I literally just
told you okay
come here Mia come here
uni
you like your new backyard
is like a new backyard it matches your
fur colors
what are you sniffing around in there
don't mess up their strain dude
all right following the family outside
yeah day 225 day four
day four of this Vlog day 225 of the
whole
series remember it was um oh yeah it was
all bumpy yeah so I think they're
getting ready to lay the towel over here
oh my goodness almost trip what was that
oh a post
a lot more tile has been laid hey no why
do you always gotta step on Mounds I
know why but I still have to ask them a
parent
look at all this beautiful tile
dang this is nice
remember I told you I was like wait I
think they're doing it wrong unless
they're gonna place it and then move
move oh so they're placing they're
cutting it yeah okay like a planter yeah
so originally we thought they messed up
because
um what we really liked about the design
is that there is bits and pieces of
vegetation in between like the
hardscaping yeah so there's Planters and
so when we saw them building it from
over from inside uh
this is all Hardscape like where's the
softscape
just put it I didn't even ask for it he
was like this is gonna look good so he
would break it all up so here isn't that
beautiful we're just gonna have random
green right here yeah so that's gonna be
awesome you can see that they already
drew the line they're gonna cut so there
is gonna be like the vegetation here so
it breaks it up so it's not hard
surfaces everywhere but this looks
freaking dope look at the monkey man
over there
get her
CUNY
so yeah we got all this laid out now
got all this so it's gonna curve
again yeah
it's gonna be curved oh yeah that yellow
line specifically
like super angular like hard Corners
hard edges yeah I wanted everything flow
and like
so they're gonna start cutting the tile
this way
so it's just like folds everywhere all
of this is gonna be the turf
area
you know what's really cool is
this right here it's gonna break up all
the monotony if you will of just all
this gray oh what the
she always runs and points are snout in
her crotch must smell funny in there no
she's like I have no comeback
um but yeah you see here this is all
gonna be walkway so that's why it's not
pressed here oh yeah yeah well that's
pounded over there
okay
oh yeah this platform's built
calm down okay
platform this thing's nice
here yep a little fire pit goes right
there he's the chair
yeah I have a statue and our favorite
part is that this whole backyard feels
very inclusive because you could have
the fireplace here but then you're
facing the house and people in the hot
tub and you can Grill over there
there's a cover over there Mama saying
yep
I'm gonna be grilling over there
yeah big dining table right there
chairs
yeah Mama gets to read all her books in
her uh she does mama loves to read
that's cool why is your microphone there
because it's put on the side so you can
hear you oh wait guys
well we could do
okay cool let me see
yeah oh that was it
oh nice job
but yeah this is the progress
progress so far here's the cooking
station it's a built-in grill which is
freaking cool because
um I'm not sure if I showed you guys
this already but yeah they laid the
cement
direct gas line right there into the
house so no propane needed no charcoal
like it'll literally operate like a
stove which makes cooking really easy
and if you've ever cooked outside you
can make a big mess you don't just take
a Hose Spray everything out so super
easy to clean and in this uh section I'm
gonna have a fridge too so it'll be
really easy to prep for barbecues
because one of the biggest pains in the
butt is when you buy all the meat and
all the stuff and you're gonna cook
outside you have to constantly either
bring it in and out and in and out or
you got to get a cooler but now when we
have barbecues or people hanging out I
could have drinks to stock I could have
the the carne asada in here already
doesn't have to take up any space in the
inside fridge so I'm really really
excited about that one is
that one's way more white yeah so that
tile we're putting it on your cooking
stations yeah at the bottom that brown
part yeah so the whole thing will tie in
and then we're gonna add a bunch of
rocks like this I'll be white down here
too yeah we're gonna cover this wall and
then we're gonna get a bunch of plants
to cover up that one so that'll be all
green all white well green for plants
not because I think they're gonna take
it like that I hope so I wouldn't yeah
and then it'll be a very modern
Mediterranean look which is what we're
trying to go for right taika yeah
yeah under to the pool no there's a
bunch of Nails in there like I could
just jump okay I don't know what day
this is but we got an update and this
one's really cool because we've been
watching them
carve all day
and the backyard is starting to take
shape and look at me this is standing
here in front of me
what do you want from a young lady
oh what are you drinking some good mango
drink yeah so check it out
so right here
we're gonna have plants
we're gonna put some plants here yeah
like a nice little tree which we think
is super cool I think it's a really
unique feature because now we're
bringing like the outside kind of in a
little bit usually like when you're
underneath like this patio thing there's
no plants but we want it to like have
pretty much the whole house feel like
one like inside outside big happy family
so we got plants being planted right
here
in this under this patio area and plants
that's going to get pulled in from right
there too
no worries
this so this is what they've been
carving all day it's nice and curved
cool design
and look at that look at that it's all
curved all the way around like that
and then we got this cool little walkway
that's curved all the way over there too
it's all done by hand too I know it's
not cool like you could see the red and
the way that um coloring
the mark
so it really kind of like softens it up
because in the last couple of
um takes or like Clips you'll see that
you just see all Stone right and it just
feels like a rock hard backyard
obviously we don't have any of the
vegetation in
but once you start seeing the curvatures
kind of just like smoothed it out once
you start getting the vegetation the
green the turf it's gonna look so
nice
that's
good yeah so this is my favorite part of
the design bringing the like landscaping
and the softscape Into The Hardscape
over there too that's where all the
plants are going to be so having this
like juxtaposition of like hard textures
with plants it's gonna look good and
then here we just we literally just came
back from it now
um we just picked out our Stone that's
gonna cover this whole wall
so that's going to be really great and
then we're gonna uh add a bunch of
plants I feel like we've seen the same
thing over and over
what
I saw a lot of bugs in there and pee pee
water pee water yeah Mia come here okay
by myself no I'll help you please
okay if in the last take I had no idea
what day it is I for sure don't know
what day it is but I do know that this
is like the very very last step before
they start really making the backyard
come to life so in the last take you
guys saw how they did all the curves
well look at this now they sealed it
with concrete
so this whole thing is now permanently
in place all the curves all of that they
started to level the ground because
that's where we're gonna put the turf
and everything
and the biggest biggest change okay
comes on this side
which is pretty freaking cool
because they're about to lay down
concrete on this so if you guys look
from back in the day there's like a big
like like little drain area because it
was just rough dirt but now today they
flattened it and the whole day the house
was shaking
because I have to do this thing that
pounds the floor so that it stays like
Rock Solid so that they could lay the
cement on it see look even when I step
like you don't really see sand or dust
like really popping off because it's
been pounded into the floor and this is
going to be Altar and they're doing like
a really cool design
that's curved like that oh my God what
are you doing over there
I swear to God all this dirt is going to
be so well fertilized because that's
where she's been pissing and
but you know how our backyard has like
this whole curve theme
right like from all that grass over
there this pathway over here so all of
this is going to be grass and it's cool
that it's not just a hard line it's
curved on this side too
and
um probably by the end of next week
we're gonna see this entire back part
get fill the cement this is going to be
a planter for bushes so we'll have like
tons of privacy
and uh this is why because you guys know
I'm freaking Meathead but the reason why
I'm so excited is once they put the
concrete here
that is like the first major step of
building our outdoor gym
so this whole area from that wall all
the way up to like maybe like here is
about 30 feet we're gonna build a patio
cover that comes over and so we're gonna
store our gym out here so it'll kind of
be almost like we have our own like
outdoor Venice and I love training
outside especially in the beautiful like
Vegas weather in the summer it's gonna
be crazy so that's like that might be
like just one month where it's like Peak
heat but the rest is gonna be amazing
and when we're out here studying this
I didn't realize but our backyard from
this angle has the sickest view watch
check it out
look at that
isn't that crazy
feels like we just like live in like
Colorado or like Utah or something
but like this
is the edge of the city
like we literally live at the very very
edge of the city
and as I walk
over here
which I've showed you guys before
um but we can see the strip
let me let me run
I mean it's so athletic it's crazy but
yep all the way
over here so we live at the very edge of
the city
see the strip down there
see the mountains over here
and
this is our backyard
so that'll be it for this vlog
can't wait to show you guys
the next one about the house where it's
going to be a major major update I know
a lot of you guys are like early 20s
late 20s
watching this channel if any of you guys
have any questions about building homes
or backyards pool Landscaping financing
loans all that stuff
um if you have any questions I would
love to share anything I've ever gained
so leave it in the comments below and
I'll do my best to answer all right
peace